how do you convince an executive
whomever
making these decisions that you are the
person for it without being
overconfident
well that's a tricky thing you know it's
like any other relationship
you know women love a dominant you know
persistent man until he becomes a
stalker you know what i mean it's like
yeah you always hear the oh i didn't
want to go out with him but he just
liked me so much and just kept doing you
know
and it charms and it's so easy to
go over that line and it's the same
thing
you know with i mean they're not that
they're the same
it's the exact same relationship in that
we want something from them or sometimes
they want something from us
and you know it's always the seesaw of
who's hotter at that moment who's ever
hotter
um you know has the power and what's
funny is it breaks down to even
you know it's so clear you can see where
you rate
with like if they come to you for lunch
then you're hotter than them that day
if you go to them you know and it's
because la is so
like vast and it takes so much driving
the
the person that wants something from the
other person has to schlep
you know and so it's very interesting to
see that like oh i would never slept for
that person but then you go
but then you want something you go okay
you know like so it's it all
it's the same thing with anything that
you
are trying to sell and you know but as a
director it's very different because
you know i'm so you know i it's this old
adage you know if it ain't on the page
it ain't on the stage
writers know that and the industry knows
that
but there's a lot of great writers there
really are and the industry knows
that you know writers are like
you know the old you know stupid joke
you know you know the starlet who came
to hollywood and
you know slept with a writer you know
it's like you know
it's like she's the idiot because the
writer doesn't have that power
the director you know the pecking order
is the director star
or sometimes the star bigger than
depending on who
um but the writer you know the writer
can be replaced it's very hard to
replace the director
mid-shoot you know and so you know
they have to know that they want to
marry that director
in a much he's in char like i'm in
charge of 120 pages
he's the director is in charge of 120
million you know
dollars i mean you know writers are like
like that to a degree and you have to be
okay with that if you're gonna
you know you can't sit around and whine
about getting rewritten i used to
and then i got used to it you know i'm
like what do you what do you mean
they're gonna rewrite me what's wrong
with what i wrote
you know and then you know your agent
tells you to shut up and after about
four years you understand
that now you know everybody is getting
scripts
i mean brookheimer kind of taught me
that like he bring on a lot of writers
because he understands it's a product
and he he'd know the writer that
writes the best explosions he knows the
writer that writes the best
you know buttons on a scene you know or
the one that knows how to
get the dude writing right you know and
so
um that's why he never fails you know or
if he does it's so rare
and but the the money that the studio
has to invest in a director is just a
different deal
than than the writer